probably not surprising but interesting
subrama is an actor key grip and owner
of Sparta grippy joins us tonight Stu
thanks so much for coming on so you've
seen this I mean the rest of us would I
guess assume that a lot of actors who
were of course against the Second
Amendment probably don't know a lot
about guns but you're saying you have
seen actors mishandle firearms
yeah thanks for having me on first of
all Tucker I appreciate it um but uh
yeah in my industry you know we we deal
with a lot of firearms scenarios
obviously we've got a lot of Hollywood
people that uh will vilify a fire vilify
firearms and then end up on their TV
shows and movies and glorify them in
those instances and you know it's just
the hypocrisy of it um you know I kind
of you know I try and be professional on
set but you run into those instances
where you've watched somebody you know
make statements on their TV shows or
their you know their interviews and and
then you see them on the sets working
and they're you know trying to be you
know uh using the Firearms uh it's just
just comical
well it's it's a it's a little weird
um that people who think guns are evil
would be as you said glorifying their
use playing the tough guy you know
pointing guns in people's faces on the
set I mean have you ever seen an actor
decline a role
because it involved guns
uh I'm sure the paychecks far outweigh
their uh you know far outweigh their uh
their feelings towards firearms
so um I guess it goes without saying
that a lot of these are people who
really just don't know anything about
firearms
that's correct I mean you know you see
them have these conversations on the
news channels and with politicians and
everything else about firearms and then
you know you hear things I mean I grew
up around guns I grew up in Montana I'm
an avid Outdoorsman I've been hunting my
entire life and you know you you hear
them talk about uh firearms and and they
totally don't understand even the
mechanics of them to begin with and
they're trying to make their their point
across of why they're so bad and evil
and everything else and you know honest
hard-working you know citizens that you
know love love guns and you know my guns
have never harmed anybody or never been
in the hands of anybody that would do
harm and
um
you know you just look at those
scenarios and then you're you kind of
have to keep quiet on these movie sets
and end up working with these
individuals
and and not just you I've you know been
on you know lots of different sets and
there is this huge divide between the
people who are getting paid the most and
who are on camera and then everybody the
army of people off camera who you never
see I would say the majority of Hume
don't share the politics of the people
on camera has that been your experience
absolutely not I I you know in my in my
industry you know there's always the you
know the conversations behind the camera
and you know I think a lot of people
probably feel very similar to the way
that I feel
um when it when it comes to these issues
you know but of course we're not making
the 10 million dollar paycheck so you
know we're just there to do our job and
do it to the best of our ability
well I for one wish you were making the
10 million dollar I do too Stu thanks
for joining us today I appreciate it
thanks for having me I appreciate it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight